Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
The Loki season 2 finale wrapped up
a number of overarching plot threads
heading into Marvel Phase 6 and Avengers 5.
A lot of you have been asking
what happened to he who remains after
Loki broke the loom and created the New World
tree version of the wider multiverse.
Sitting atop the remains of he remains citadel
at the end of time in his former chair.
The chair that he's sitting in was the chair that he
who remains was just sitting in earlier in the episode.
there are a bunch of scenes that they didn't
include the ending of Episode six
to explain what actually happened to him.
So we'll explain what happened to him
between Loki leaving his citadel at the end of time
and then fixing the multiverse.
Marvel is still currently committed
to the Council of Kangs
versus the new Avengers in Avengers five at the moment.
so just in general right now, the whole concept of
kangs is still something that Marvel is working on.
In the writer for Loki,
Season one is now writing Avengers five two.
He already wrote Avengers
six Secret Wars that that wasn't clear.
So there's a lot of energy from the Loki series
just in general
that's being baked in to Avengers
five and Avengers six.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
We have What if season two episodes?
I'll be doing videos for pretty soon,
and they just started releasing the Loki
and the one Division Blu ray.
So we're giving away a couple of copies
all year through to enter.
You just be a subscriber and let me know what
you want them to do with Loki during Avengers five.
In Avengers six, he's
kind of the most powerful character in the MCU right
now, next to people like Scarlet Witch
with all of her chaos, Magic.
but at the end of the finale, Loki time slips back to
he remains did it all at the end of time.
Before Sylvie originally killed him
during the events of Loki Season one in that finale,
the moment he arrived in was this moment here,
after she lost all patients with him,
it made the lunge across the table at him like,
That's enough.
Loki tries to stop her.
They had their battle between the two of them
where he tries to convince her not to do it.
That all took place during the season
one finale Originally, Sylvie pushed him back
through the portal, back to the TVA, his time
slipping started.
She proceeded to kill he who remains,
causing all the problems they had containing the loom
during season two,
basically setting the plot of season two off
when Loki comes back to that same moment in the season
two finale,
he's figured out how to control his time slipping
and he remains, realizes what's happened.
Like, okay, you understand how to do this now?
He pauses,
Sylvie in time so they can have a chat
just between the two of them,
where he reveals that he orchestrated
the events of season one and season two.
These moments here,
knowing that everything with the time slipping
was going to happen, like he did it on purpose.
It was all part of his grand design, He reveals
they never would have been able to fix the loom.
All of the victor timely stuff that he's set up at the
beginning of Season two was part of his grand design,
but that was part of the path that he was laying out
for Loki to learn how to evolve into the God
of stories, the God form of Loki,
the whole idea is that an every time loop
that they experienced the loom would always destroy
all the extra timelines no matter what.
Like this explosion would always happen, no matter what
reset so that only the sacred timeline remained.
And he just rebuild the TVA
when the timeline rebooted again.
and this was happening
over and over and over again, many, many, many times
That's why if he told Loki that he didn't
fully understand things yet,
like he hadn't fully gained the power to command time
just biologically without any technology,
that he should try a couple thousand more loops.
all because he who remains was still trying
to get Loki to take over management
of the sacred timeline from him.
But his secret plan was to push Loki through all these
time loops to learn to unlock his God of stories.
Power which then Loki shows
that he's already learned how to do.
When he pauses Sylvie by flicking his finger
the reason he remains created this elaborate time loop
for Loki to go through over and over again to evolve
this way was because he remains wanted a more
omnipotent being to be managing things after he left,
someone who wouldn't be dependent upon technology.
noticed during those final moments.
He also reveals that the Council of Kangs
exist outside of time in their base,
and nothing Loki does will be able to stop them
from already existing out there.
That's because their base
is outside of time in a different dimension,
like the TVA, like a pocket dimension
it's not affected by anything that either of them
did during Loki Season two,
even when Loki fixed the multiverse, Loki decides
that he's going to beat he who remains.
Finally, by not playing his game,
he was offered two choices
Choose the loom, keeping things status quo or no loom,
and let any and all king variants
run wild, Creating a new King multiverse work
just as bad as the first one, if not worse.
Loki chooses his own third option to break the loom
and then sacrifice himself
by becoming a custodian of sorts to the multiverse
using his newly unlocked god of stories.
Power of controlling time to keep the tree
that is the multiverse healthy.
sort of like a cosmic gardener
keeping the tree of all the timelines healthy,
which gets back to his last conversation with Mobius.
He asks him,
How do you choose what to prune and what to allow?
because he has the power to change anything
in the timelines that he wants.
He's asking, Mobius, how do you know what to change
But when he returns with all the timelines in tow,
he remains citadel at the end of time.
Looks like it's been reduced to rubble
like it's years later in this decade
to almost nothing is kind of like a continue
to decay over a long period of time.
so here's what they did not show in that ending scene
after Loki left
he who remains for the final time when he leaves
Loki and he remains, allows Sylvie to kill
he who remains
like she originally did during the season one finale,
because the moment that they're in here is back
during the events of the Season one finale.
remember Loki jump back to this time period.
so the idea is that the minute that Loki time slips
back to the TVA, Sylvie became unpaused.
Loki, who remains unpaused.
Then they have that same moment of her killing him
like she did during season one.
then she escapes to Broxton, Oklahoma, and begins
that part of her time loop.
It's happening in the past. Remember?
then when Loki is ascending to he who remains chair,
turning it into his own throne
with all the timelines
he remains has been dead for a long time.
So long that his citadel decayed to the point
where almost nothing is left of it.
Just some framework in part of his chair.
The whole idea is that Loki is repairing it
with his power like that.
Kintsugi method Golden joinery,
turning it into his golden throne,
meant to be fashioned after Odin's golden throne
that he used to sit on one of the other
important details here to the kind of flows with this.
If you couldn't tell his new horns are made
of that same Kinski style
with the golden veins of the rock
from the citadel in them.
It's meant to be his God and Loki costume, his Loki,
who remains costume
because that's basically what he becomes.
Loki, who remains So a lot of people were like,
Wait a minute,
he who remains knew about everything that happened
during Loki season two.
If he had this even greater, deeper play in it play,
would he have allowed himself to be killed?
part of the whole idea is that he wanted to leave the
like he didn't want to work anymore.
He gotten so bored over the eons.
So he was just trying to push Loki to the point where
he could do all this on his own without any technology.
And he was just waiting for that to happen, to allow
himself to be killed, to be perma killed, basically.
So if it wasn't clear, he who remains is supposed to be
perma dead heading forward after the end of Loki
season two in remember because Loki controls everything
inside, all the timelines, Loki
can also control everything that he remains does
now when it comes to Avengers five, though,
as he told Loki, the Council of Kangs is still out
there, still coming for everyone.
There's still a threat.
Loki can't stop them as they exist right now
because they're in their own little pocket dimension
outside of the timeline in Loki can only control stuff
inside the timelines. But.
That's why they have that moment at the ending
with the TVA talking about Kang the Conqueror
from Ant-Man and the WASP Quantumania being defeated
by a bunch of Avengers from the 616 universe.
Basically,
the TVA is now actively focusing on monitoring
the Kang variants from across the multiverse
that'll wind up culminating during Avengers five.
In Avengers six.
It also explains how the TVA can continue
to be involved
in the events of Deadpool three
because they will be a big part of Deadpool three.
and as far as Marvel being committed
to the whole counsel of Kang's storyline in Avengers
five, the way they've set things up is they can change
whatever they need to change if they have to.
If things go south with Jonathan Majors
Because right now, as far as we know,
they're still waiting to find out the results
of whatever his trial winds up being would
that means is it they'll still be doing
Council of Kang's stuff in Avengers five
because it's still called Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty.
But dark is timeline.
At the very worst they would just recast Kang
and just continue to use the characters
the same way they were going to before
with the Council of Kangs.
that's part of the reason why during the Loki series,
particularly Loki season one,
they had a bunch of different variants of Loki
that look nothing like Tom Hiddleston.
There are a lot of people in earlier videos
that were asking about some specific contract
clauses that Jonathan Majors
had about playing the different Kang variants.
there was a lot of confusion over his contract
because part of it stated that he would play
all the different variants of Kang,
which is what they showed during Ant-Man,
the WASP Quantumania Post-Credits scene.
but his contract didn't give him the right
to be the only person to play Kang variants,
just that Marvel could ask him
to play all the Kang variants if they wanted to.
Not that he had exclusive rights to do that.
right now
we're still in the middle of Marvel Phase five too.
So Marvel has given themselves a couple of years
till they have to deal with Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty,
so they don't need to actually use the Kang character
or any of the Kang variants for a good long while.
part of the reason why they've done that is just
to give this whole thing with Jonathan Majors
time to clear itself up
so they can either bring him back in a couple of years
for Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty, or recast the role
with another actor in a couple of years.
So even though it sucks, we have to wait
a couple more years for another Avengers
movie to come out like it's going to be 84 years
between Avengers Endgame in Avengers five, right.
Now Marvel's just kind of using that delay
to their advantage,
just to let things behind the scenes clear up before
they actually need to use the Kang character again
for like they really need to use him.
so when you're looking at
like all these different movies and Disney Plus series
that are still coming out the next couple of years,
do not expect to see
a bunch of Kang or Council of Kang stuff
happening in the background.
This would be a lot of post-credits scenes,
a lot of X-Men stuff happening, like we have Deadpool
three coming up, big multiverse storyline,
a lot of TVA's stuff going on during that next year,
But for example, there's only one Marvel movie
coming out next year and it is Deadpool three.
These because they're so confident in it,
they basically delayed all their other movies till 2025
just to give them time to work.
A lot of their issues out behind the scenes
because there's a lot of issues, a lot of chaos
going on behind the scenes at Marvel right now.
so like the end of Loki season two
is like the last time you're meant to see a Jonathan
Majors Kang like Kang just in general
show up for a good long while like Kevin.
Foggy is the real control of the multiverse.
Kevin who remains
and he's paused him in time for just a couple years
just the way that all the problems
that he's having to see if they need
to recast the character, I'm sure there's going to be
a ton of questions about everything that's going on.
There's a lot of announcements
that they made recently about completely different
shows, like a bunch of footage that's been dropping.
So of course they'll do videos for everything
as we get more news about it all.
if you have any questions that I didn't address
in this video about any of the characters
or going forward, what's going to be happening,
just write them in the comments below.
everyone click here for my Loki Season 2 Alternate
ending for the Beyonder version of Loki
that he evolved into and click here for that Moon Knight
Season two announcement that Marvel just made.
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!